foreign
night in the capital of Peru protesters
clashed with police as they tried to
stop angry peruvians from reaching the
Parliament building
thousands marched through Lima demanding
the resignation of president
dinaboluarte
some threw rocks and bottles and
security forces responded with tear gas
several protesters and police were
injured today the people are rising up
not because we want to but because of
the conviction we have for a better Peru
president Dina palawate has to resign
an empty building in the city's historic
Center caught fire although the cost is
yet unknown the protesters are calling
for the resignation of the president
that the solution of Congress fresh
elections and a new constitution
God will help us we will win sooner than
later if she does not resign the people
will kick her out and we will die for
our children
thousands journeyed from Southern
provinces for a two-day National strike
[Applause]
Jessica Mendoza traveled from Juan
cabelica an Andean region in central
Peru I'm Marching for my children and
grandchildren Dina leave we don't want
to see you anymore you're stubborn and
you must leave
in the south of the country hundreds
tried to take over the airports in July
the president addressed the nation on
Thursday evening she called for dialogue
but vowed to prosecute protesters who
had broken the law quien Los financia a
new protest is no social agenda you are
outside the law you want to break the
rule of law and generate chaos and
disorder you want to take power
more than 50 people have died in
protests since former president Pedro
Castillo was ousted and arrested six
weeks ago
that's the question for many peruvians
most disapprove of baluata's governments
and believe she should start considering
stepping down
[Music]
opinion polls say 71 of peruvians don't
agree with boluarte and half of the
country support the protesters demands
the state of emergency in the country
has been extended nearly 100 roads have
been blocked the economic losses are
enormous and there appears to be no end
in sight to the spiraling unrest Marina
Sanchez al-jacida Lima
[Music]